all right i've got something really
scary for you today all right i'm gonna
play some video for you
of a woman
who could be could be
your child's teacher hopefully she's not
but she could be
a viewer who i won't name sent me this
video this is from
um uh a teacher
uh in her school district
um who did a video on youtube called a
lesson plan
and it wasn't a lesson plan it was an
explanation of why this teacher whose
name appears to be carly sue based on
the youtube channel that this has been
uploaded to
this is an explanation of why this
teacher wasn't in school it was a
message to i guess her students and the
reason she wasn't in school is because
she refused to get vaccinated or be
tested for covet
she goes on in this video to spread all
sorts of disinformation about the
vaccine viruses masks we're going to
look at a little bit and just understand
there are hundreds thousands of people
like this who are teaching your kids
right now
right now take a listen to this
hi everybody hope you're having a good
day
i
just got done walking my my pup hans on
this beautiful sunday
and i wanted to make a video because uh
you obviously can see that i'm not in
class today
right and i wanted to go over a few
things
one of those things being
explaining why i'm not there you deserve
to know where your teacher is please
first thing is i'm not sick
uh i've not
i don't have a cold i don't have a sore
throat i feel great
uh the reason that i'm not at school
today is because
the administration has enforced um
the
jab
mandate as well as if you refuse the jab
then
they're requiring testing and
i
have a strong
a very strong
uh stance on that i feel
that it's unconstitutional
um i
will never this is not a law professor
by the way and that there's nothing
unconstitutional so
we're starting with remember this is a
message to her students never ever ever
inject my body
with
something that is experimental
it doesn't qualify as a
real
vaccine
so she's whispering vaccine remember
that it is a vaccine
and the pfizer one has been fda approved
it's gene therapy it is not gene therapy
um
and
if you asked any of them not one person
would be able to tell you what is in
the shot uh the truth is the ingredients
are known they are listed anybody can
google this
now they she would probably say well the
ingredient list is a lie
but that's a different argument now
so um
i've done a lot of research and there it
is
there it is the holy grail of spreading
disinformation i've done research the
past two years about this and i knew it
would get to this point and i knew that
i would make this decision
i didn't know exactly how it was all
going to play out but
i just feel really bad that you guys
have to deal with it firsthand i feel
horrible that you have to
um
the problem is that they're having to
deal with her she's the problem
see this all play out because it's
it's painful and it's uh okay so i'm
gonna skip forward because later in this
clip i mean there's a lot of nonsense
here but then she goes into just
spreading straight up imaginary cuckoo
stuff
about um medical disinformation take a
look at this
oxygen actually kills the virus
the right to breathe the right to make
your own choices
i'm guessing this is anti-mask oxygen
kills the virus so the mask is bad
it's a free country or we thought it was
but it's not we have to fight for our
freedom and if you believe in freedom if
you believe in living free
then you gotta do something about it you
gotta have some courage you gotta step
up
and
decide what you believe is right
so just know that i'm praying for you
guys i care about you so deeply and
um
stand strong okay
god wins and
just persevere finish strong we're
almost there can you imagine your kid
being taught in school by this woman
uh and there's so much we can say uh
obviously
there are probably some parents who like
this stuff okay
it seems like a dystopian nightmare to
me that this is the woman that might be
teaching our children but there's
another thing i want to mention here
with all of these people
they all seem to have the idea they
don't they don't seem to question
that
they might have figured something out
about covid
that would change the entire pandemic
that the entire global medical community
hasn't figured out
uh they did their research on their home
computer
and have figured things out that public
health experts
epidemiologists immunologists
pulmonologists
around the world
haven't figured out
it's easy to call that merely delusional
but it's it's really a form of
incredible arrogance in a sense the the
idea that they may have done that now
discoveries happen discoveries happen
and they come from from different places
but the idea that these folks are the
ones that by doing research figured out
hey
all we got to do to get rid of covet is
don't wear masks
because oxygen kills the virus so just
put oxygen on the virus virus dies you
don't need masks you don't need a
vaccine and also
throwing in god's stuff too as well
it is delusional
it's dangerous to have these folks
teaching kids but there's a level of
arrogance as well that they may have
stumbled upon this
and this is a major issue with social
media actually this is i've mentioned
before i'm almost done now reading the
book technology by neil postman
you this is a must-read book for anyone
participating in social media or news i
think it's imperative everybody read it
um there's this
reality that neil postman wrote about
that when you get a new technology it's
easy to say
let's make sure it's only used in these
ways but not in those ways and the truth
is once you've got a technology the
technology changes the culture in
irreversible ways
one of the ways in which the internet
high-speed internet internet on our
phones and social media have changed
culture
is that folks who don't really know
anything
now are empowered to do what they
believe is research and to believe their
opinions about anything at all are just
as valid
as
those of
actual experts now we've talked about
the crisis of expertise this is not this
is not the fallacy of um uh
you know saying
uh if someone's an expert then
if the only reason you trust someone is
because they are claiming expertise then
that's a fallacy we're talking about
actual experts here and this is one of
the um
seemingly irreversible impacts of
widespread high-speed internet
mobile phones smartphones and social
media and this is really scary stuff and
she's uh she's teaching people she's
teaching kids although maybe not much
longer i guess we'll see
when we're talking about sleep we always
hear about how much sleep people get but
often neglected in the conversation is
the quality of that sleep which is just
as important and science shows that
lowering your body temperature during
sleep can help you be more rested and
achieve better sleep and that's where
our sponsor chili sleep comes in chilly
sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to help you
improve your sleep comes in two
varieties the uhler sleep system and the
cube sleep system that's what i have on
my bed both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make your bed as cold as 55
degrees i choose 60
you can make it as hot as 115 degrees if
that's your thing
i don't feel hot anymore at night no
more sweating i'm sleeping better and i
love it i also have the chili sleep
chili blanket which helps keep me cool
on top as well they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video